all this is pride month it is a time to
recognize and celebrate diversity and
also to focus on health and healing the
center wants to get out that message
Lorna Grady joins us to talk about some
of the resources that are available
Lauren good morning good morning well
the center Prides itself on being a safe
space providing health care resources
and a new Pharmacy that just opened up
in April and while the lgbtqia plus
Community celebrates Pride the center's
Chief Operating Officer Brian hoser
urges people to be safe he recommends
being on prep HIV prevention if you are
sexually active and not monogamous and
then there's a concern of monkey pox
spread through skin-to-skin contact
monkey pox is an issue it's wearing its
head up again so we're always make sure
we let our community know that we're
here we hear we do vaccinations and
we're here to provide all the
information you may need about that
their Pharmacy has a monkey pox vaccine
event on Fridays and staff say Nevada
ranks high in sexually transmitted
diseases and the center is the largest
HIV testing center in southern Nevada
they also work to serve the community
Through advocacy health and wellness and
connection and coming up in the next
half hour their medical director talks
about their transgender resources
following the state passing several
lgbtqia plus Centric bills live in The
Newsroom Lauren negretti 8 News Now